la tarification dynamique ce n'est pas
toujours une bonne affaire pour le
consommateur on en parle chaque fois que
les stars passent par chez nous par
exemple pour la tournée nord-américaine
de bluespringsteen certains billets
valent plus de 6000 dollars ça fait
beaucoup pour danser dans le noir parce
qu'aujourd'hui la technologie permet au
marchand d'optimiser leur profits en
fonction de la demande c'est ça le
principe de la tarification dynamique la
technique est déjà bien établie dans les
industries aériennes et haute-lierre on
l'applique aussi dans certaines stations
de ski plus les billets se vendent plus
le prix augmente même Hydro-Québec le
fait entre autres avec son programme
flexbe les clients qui participent
payent plus cher leur électricité en
période de pointe mais moins cher que
les autres le reste du temps donc les
prix peuvent monter et descendre mais
dans le domaine culturel Danilo Dantas
professeur de marketing à HEC Montréal
affirme que le consommateur est rarement
gagnant avec la tarification dynamique
il n'a en fait jamais entendu parler de
baisse de prix pour les billets de
spectacle certains experts disent même
qu'une partie de l'offre de concert sera
de plus en plus réservée au mieux entier
c'est quand même drôle de penser que les
meilleurs sièges pour voir le chanteur
de la classe ouvrière iront au plus
riche